so Grantchester comes to India for the
first time give us your thoughts and
impressions about playing here the
biggest part about any country is its
people yeah and I think people are
extremely friendly and warm-hearted and
that's that's a lot of you can see that
people know history of chess and they
know literature so I enjoy being here
back in 2013 was obviously one of the
most intense and also best experiences
of my life so far it was fascinating to
see how much interest that was in in in
chess here in India not only for fans
but also from from media Kolkata is is
it just crazy City so be interested to
see it not only from the media but also
because the media is sort of what's also
farted also from the pants yeah people
here are very warm I mean it's an honor
actually and I'm very happy that I got
picked and the grand gesture is
happening in India and especially in
this city Calcutta where like there are
so many fans and they really try really
hard to support you when you're and
stuff like this it really motivates me I
just saying all the different people who
were at playing site both inside and
outside just trying to clamor to get
autographs before we got on the bus and
came back to the hotel it's it's very
clear there's a lot of interest in shots
a lot of enthusiasm for it now of course
in large part that's due to due to
vicious career being being the world
champion well it's a one tournament
where things really feel different of
course there are a lot of good
tournaments but first of all for me it's
very important to have at least one big
tournament in India because it seems
like over here people always reading
about me or following you playing
somewhere else and it's really nice to
have a nice prestigious event here
so already last year I was very happy
but then that this year game plan and
Tata Steel managed to join the Chester I
think raises that a notch so that a lot
of the fancy I can say all the top 10
and I think it's a great experience
you